we're doing multiply and divide
fractions today traditionally
multiplying and dividing fractions can
be a little bit tricky but it isn't lets
you really understand what's going on
okay
to do not to play dividing fractions how
many to understand it is just to think
about multiplying and dividing when
there's whole numbers right whole of
this okay so we're gonna take hold up as
out and our basis and then we're gonna
use that as kind of like out out you
know our part to get two fractions right
so let's start with a simple example
okay if I say look I've got these blocks
okay I've got these blocks and you can
see that each block is they have one two
three four individual units okay so if I
say look I've got two of these box sets
of blocks and each one has four right in
fact I've got a whole bunch to have four
so I have two of these fours does that
make sense
like as a way of speaking I've got two
of them that's exactly right there to
force would be a strong way of saying
but I'm actually including that word of
because like two of these fours or two
of these fives or two of these tens
whatever number how many blocks like how
many do I actually have hey I have eight
right now this is a really important
thing to get this sentence down with me
right I said two of these fours right or
I suppose I would say suit force just as
a abbreviation right the two these fours
like to get to a the operation that you
did was multiplication right before you
got to eight you said two times four
right you agree with that
this is two times four make sense and
that's what gave you eight now in
exactly the same way if I step it up
okay okay yeah I apply to these Falls
now five of these fours okay so if I
replace this with a five okay if I say
five of these fours they're not gonna
have over here instead of two times four
it'll be five times four which of course
you can check out you can count it's 20
right so two of these fours find these
fours the critical thing is right number
number number number that would all see
that what a really corresponds to is
multiplication right or another way I
could say it is multiplication it means
all like verbally that's what it means
so now let's have a look at this here's
my um these are my pocket for again wow
that's really good so what have I got
here
think about the red part as a part of
the hole right because that's what
fractions are right like it's you know
okay it's pieces then what is this in
terms of fractions well it's half the
red part is half of four right do you
agree with that that's how you would
word it I'd say that that red part is
half of for half a four now of course
you can count
I've chosen a nice simple numbers so
it's two right but where there's two
come from well just like here to these
fours is two times four half of 4 is 1/2
times 4 right again you see that same
parallel right miss a word means this
symbol right they the same thing and
that's why it gives you now you already
told me the answer is - I was - how do
we work with this fraction here this
fraction of this number in order to get
2 then I'll do it with clear suggestion
okay so I said four times 1/2 that's one
way of thinking about four times our
heart is the same as 4 divided by 2
I agree with that they're the same
another way of thinking about it I'm
gonna come back to this way in a second
so I'm gonna leave that written up there
another way it's just look at this see
her for right I've written is it a whole
number
he's a whole number I could also write
as a fraction right do you agree that
four over one at four I really equipment
they're the same number right thing so
in order to get to I've really gone 1
times 4 and 2 times 1 right what that
would give me is well Skippy we write
this line all the new write up for and
on the denominator 2 which of course
gives us 2 like we saw before okay
that's a half before again our voyage of
this one is equally simple okay how
would you read this
how would you win it I would say
probably a quarter or for a quarter for
which verbally of course I can translate
that into 1/4 times 4 which you already
can see is just 1 right 1 times 4
divided by 4 times 1 that's just 1 okay
so this key idea of of multiplication of
multiplication